[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de France 24
cubrir las necesidades de protección y
de anticoncepción de las mujeres es
indispensable aporta contra las tazas de
muerte materna y neonatal y permite a
las poblaciones avanzar en su nivel de
estudios y de sus posibilidades de
desarrollo económico y social un estudio
de la revista científica de lancet midió
la combinación de métodos
anticonceptivos la prevalencia y la
demanda satisfecha por edad y por estado
civil en 204 países y territorios
Ese es nuestro tema de conversación en
esta ocasión antes de dar paso a las
invitadas veamos algunos datos
en 1970 se calcula que el 28% de las
mujeres en edad reproductiva alrededor
del mundo podía usar métodos
anticonceptivos probados para 2019 esa
tasa pasó a ser del 48%. El Avance Es
evidente y positivo sin embargo millones
de mujeres no entran en esos incrementos
el estudio realizado por la revista
científica de lancet evidenció que en
2019 de 1.200 millones de mujeres que
necesitaron anticoncepción 163 millones
No tuvieron acceso a ella aunque querían
evitar la maternidad en algunos ejemplos
hacia Oriental y del sudeste gozaron
junto a Oceanía del mayor uso de
contraconceptivos modernos con 65% y las
mujeres completaron sus necesidades en
90%. mientras que África subsahariana
solo contó con 24% de anticonceptivos
modernos y 52% de demanda satisfecha una
cuarta parte de las mujeres con menos
acceso se ubicó entre los 15 y los 24
años y la conversación es con Sandra
Castañeda Martínez coordinadora general
de la red de salud de las mujeres
latinoamericanas y del Caribe y con
Salomé Valencia médica feminista e
integrante del grupo médico por el
derecho a decidir y de la mesa por la
salud de las mujeres en Colombia gracias
a ambas y vamos a comenzar Salomé las
mujeres tenemos derecho a decidir
libremente Si queremos o no tener hijos
cuántos Y cuándo Si es el caso Cómo es
el acceso a los anticonceptivos tan
importante para ese derecho
bueno el acceso a los anticonceptivos es
importante Pues porque es la oportunidad
que tenemos las mujeres de decidir
exactamente lo que tú dijiste Cuánto
tiene Cuántos hijos queremos tener si
queremos o no tener hijos entonces es la
posibilidad básicamente de ejercer el
derecho a nuestra autonomía reproductiva
yo creo que eso es lo más lo más
importante y Sandra los anticonceptivos
previenen el embarazo temprano o el
embarazo no deseado también además de
una serie de problemáticas sociales de
grandísimas como la deserción escolar
como el freno a las carreras
profesionales hablemos por favor de esto
para empezar a entrar en el tema
Sí bueno es que el tema de los
contraceptivos hace referencia a un
aspecto muy importante de la vida de las
mujeres que es la salud y los derechos
sexuales y los derechos reproductivos
que además es una de las áreas más
sensibles todavía es que está
relacionado no solamente con aspectos
biológicos sino también con aspectos
identitarios de las personas que de las
usuarias y en esa medida pues tiene una
vinculación estrecha y directa con
aspectos como la autonomía como la
libertad como la dignidad de las
personas y por tanto pues es un asunto
que debe ser tenido en cuenta como de
los aspectos más centrales y que son
sine qua no para el desarrollo
de la autonomía de las de las mujeres de
su proyecto vital
además y volviendo a Salomé ahora le
pregunto a usted también Sandra un gran
problema es que la inmensa mayoría de
anticonceptivos los tenemos que usar las
mujeres nos los tenemos que inyectar o
tomar o poner las mujeres así nos ha
sido Lamentablemente impuesto al menos
culturalmente diría yo llegamos al
espacio curamos el cáncer estamos
curando en sida estamos alterando las
especies pero aún no hemos podido
innovar en que los hombres también
asuman una mayor responsabilidad por esa
tarea del anticoncepción entonces
quisiera por favor desde su punto de
vista médico Pues cuál es la opinión al
respecto
en ese sentido Yo creo que la ciencia y
la medicina pues tenemos una deuda muy
grande con las mujeres y las niñas
porque siempre han sido las que han
tenido que asumir todos los efectos
adversos de estos medicamentos esto por
un lado Entonces yo creo que hay como
como dos cosas Una una una falta de un
avance fuerte de un impulso de la
ciencia en esta materia y por otro lado
pues es como un tema muy relacionado con
la estructura social que existe y en la
que en los roles en los que en los que
vivimos actualmente Y es que las mujeres
nos hacemos responsables de la
reproducción no somos las las personas
los seres responsables de la
reproducción Entonces yo creo que están
como estas dos cosas hay una necesidad
muy fuerte de involucrar exactamente a
los hombres pero también la medicina y
la ciencia tiene que avanzar en esta
materia y pues los temas más de los
roles sociales también y Sandra entonces
la responsabilidad recae principalmente
sobre nosotras las mujeres para proteger
y para y para tener hijos o no tener
hijos y poder avanzar o no avanzar en
nuestras carreras y en nuestras
vocaciones sin embargo y lo muestra el
estudio que publicó de lancet en 2019
millones y millones de mujeres en el
mundo no tuvieron acceso no solamente
anticonceptivos sino a diversidad de
anticonceptivos
por favor hablemos un poco sobre cómo
cómo es que este problema pues no se
compara y y ahí hay una incoherencia
entre la responsabilidad que nos imponen
y las facilidades que nos dan en
políticas públicas por ejemplo
claro es que cuando hablamos de salud y
derechos sexuales y derechos
reproductivos no solamente estamos
hablando de un tema puramente médico o
puramente biológico también tiene que
ver con construcciones culturales y en
nuestros medios todavía la
responsabilidad de la reproducción está
muy a cargo de las mujeres todavía no
hemos comprendido que la responsabilidad
de la reproducción y de la crianza de
Los hijos es una responsabilidad de la
sociedad en su conjunto no solamente de
las mujeres y eso claramente a pesar de
contar contratados y convenios
internacionales como hoy tenemos porque
tenemos
instrumentos internacionales que hablan
de la corresponsabilidad de todos los
miembros y todas las integrantes de la
familia con el trabajo de reproducción y
crianza de los hijos esta sigue siendo
una responsabilidad únicamente de las
mujeres Por tanto se traslada esa
responsabilidad también a lo que tiene
que ver la contracepción de cierta
manera también el hecho de tener o no
tener hijos es decir las decisiones
Sobre la reproducción También tienen una
sanción social sobre las mujeres y que
pesa casi De manera exclusiva sobre las
mujeres de tal manera que la escasez de
los productos la falta de acceso la
interrupción de las cadenas de
suministro de los anticonceptivos
definitivamente termina afectando de
manera diferencial a las mujeres las
afecta toda vez que culturalmente este
es un tema que se le carga
fundamentalmente a ellas y lo vimos
claramente en la pandemia el incremento
de los embarazos no deseados tuvo que
ver claramente con la interrupción de
los de los suministros y fue una
responsabilidad y unas consecuencias que
pesaron casi De manera exclusiva sobre
las mujeres que que tuvieron que vivir y
sufrir la enorme cantidad de embarazos
no de que tuvimos que ver durante la
pandemia de la covid 19 claro y es que
en un inciso a su intervención está
demostrado que la brecha salarial no
solamente empieza por discriminación de
género sino que en el momento que una
mujer es decide asumir la maternidad
Pues el hombre continúa elevándose en su
carrera profesional o en sus
aspiraciones vocacionales mientras que
la mujer se queda frenada por el hecho
de ser madre y deja de ser vista como
una candidata digamos importante para
las grandes compañías Pero bueno dejando
un poco eso de lado Sandra sigo con
usted porque quiero preguntarle acerca
de la situación en América Latina y es
que una de las conclusiones del informe
es que en nuestra región uno de los
métodos más utilizados fue la
esterilización femenina que es más
compleja esta ligadura de trompas que le
llaman es como procedimiento mucho más
difícil no solamente durante la cirugía
sino en el postoperatorio Y entonces la
vasectomía qué Por qué no hay más
hombres haciéndose la vasectomía cuando
la decisión y la posibilidad pues se
conclusión que no va a haber
paternidades o maternidades
claramente es que el tema de la
reproducción es como le decían tiene un
componente biológico claramente pero
tiene un enorme componente cultural hoy
todavía como le decía la responsabilidad
de la reproducción pesa fundamentalmente
sobre las mujeres y no sobre los varones
el patriarcado aquí es donde las
feministas hacemos mucho énfasis en la
importancia de de construir los patrones
sociales y culturales que están basados
en un sistema patriarcal que hotel
otorga un un enorme cantidad de
beneficios y de privilegios a los
varones en contra de los proyectos de
vida de las mujeres las mujeres mientras
que las mujeres deben hacerse cargo de
todos los temas relacionados con la
reproducción con la crianza de los hijos
en condiciones en que América Latina
sabemos que son las mujeres
quienes están en la base
alrededor de la pirámide social son
quienes sobre quienes pesan mayormente
los impactos de la pobreza y de la
desigualdad que vivimos en América
Latina y el Caribe en esas condiciones
de mayores niveles de pobreza de mayores
niveles o digamos más afectadas por la
enorme inequidad que hay en la región
deben además hacerse cargo de todos los
temas de la reproducción y de la crianza
de los hijos por eso insistimos tanto no
es solamente un tema biológico tiene que
ver con un tema cultural y sobre los
patrones culturales que se sostiene el
patriarcado que siempre termina
subordinando y excluyendo a más de la
mitad de la población que somos las
mujeres y Salomé para hacer un poco de
pedagogía Ahora que nos estamos
acercando al final del programa el
informe de la anses habla mucho de los
anticonceptivos modernos de esta
posibilidad de diversificar y de mezclar
varios métodos de planificación y que
hace más difícil todavía que las mujeres
tengan acceso En qué consisten estos
anticonceptivos mode
los anticonceptivos modernos digamos lo
que lo que lo que buscamos es que haya
una mayor cobertura en el tiempo del
anticoncepción Generalmente lo que
miramos es los anticonceptivos de más
corta duración tienen un mayor riesgo
tienen una efectividad más baja Entonces
los anticonceptivos modernos lo que
buscan es tener
efectos adversos menores pero también
tener un nivel de efectividad mayor eso
me refiero el problema con eso también
es que en muchos casos el acceso por
temas de costos pues puede ser menor
entonces pues muchas mujeres por ejemplo
en Colombia tienen que acceder a los
anticonceptivos por pago de su bolsillo
entonces Generalmente hay un rezago muy
grande un rezago importante por temas
económicos por temas de acceso
bueno y entre líneas pues lo hemos
hablado un poco Lamentablemente ya no sé
vamos quedando sin tiempo pero gracias a
ustedes Sandra y Salomé y ese digamos la
tarea para los televidentes y es pensar
en Cuáles son las poblaciones de mujeres
más desatendidas de las cuales tenemos
muchísimas en América Latina y estamos
hablando de la mujer indígena de la
mujer afrodescendiente de la mujer
raizal de las mujeres en condiciones
económicas de empobrecimiento que es el
mayor caso y pues lo vimos con diversos
ejemplos durante la pandemia Pero bueno
llegando ya al final un agradecimiento
para ambas estaban con nosotros en este
capítulo de ella soy Sandra Castañeda
Martínez en la coordinadora general de
la red de salud de las mujeres
latinoamericanas y del Caribe y Salomé
Valencia médica feminista e integrante
del grupo médico por el derecho a
decidir y de la mesa por la salud en las
mujeres de Colombia las mujeres tenemos
derecho a estar empoderadas de nuestros
derechos sexuales y reproductivos y con
esto llegamos al final de este episodio
de ella Soy síganos en France 24
[Música]